let's take some more phone calls 617 830
4752 who do have the pleasure of
speaking now oh my name is Garrett how
are you what's on your mind um hey david
soper so um I really like your show
thank you for doing that you're do and
my question for you is is um what do you
think is the future of uh third parties
in America do you think that America
needs third fourth parties and what you
personally think is the best way for
them to go forward I'm I'm personally
not a fan of guilt I not not completely
on board with Hillary Clinton yet he I'm
and I was a strong Bernie supporter and
you think the best way for third party
to advance their causes to work on
ballot initiatives for things like
ranked choice voting at state level yeah
I think that the key is and all the way
up you're sort of pointing out that
there's this issue where in the short
term the problem with the third party
Candice's is that very often they serve
only to actually get the person elected
who is furthest from the political
beliefs of those voting third parties so
if you imagine Democrats voting green
party instead of for Hillary Clinton
mathematically that would help actually
Trump or whoever's the Republican
nominee get elected I believe that the
best path forward for third parties is
Instant Runoff voting where you would be
able to go to the polls and say my top
choice is whoever and that might be a
third-party candidate if after an
initial tally that person is not viable
then my vote should go to candidate be
for example and this is a system that's
been tested hypothetically a little bit
it's also been tested in I I forget
exactly where but there is a city or
town in Vermont I believe that has
tested it that to me would be the way to
allow people to really vote for the
candidate that best aligns with their
views without risking that the person
who's furthest from their views would
end up actually winning the election so
that that's my number one way to engage
third parties in a real way okay oh I
walk on supposed to follow up with that
but yeah thank you for answering my boy
and thanks for doing what you do all
right thank you pleasure thank you so
much for the phone call